the white house is turning up the heat
in the fight against monkey pox it has
declared a public health emergency after
weeks of pressure to do more to stop the
outbreak the u.s leads the world in
infections and demand for the monkey pox
vaccine is overwhelming the supply
jonathan vigiliati is in los angeles a
major center of the outbreak jonathan
good morning
michelle good morning to you los angeles
county was one of several major cities
to declare a public health emergency
before the biden administration and now
the monkeypox virus has been detected in
48 of 50 states healthcare providers
here in california and many other hot
spots across the country are racing to
meet the soaring demand for the vaccine
vaccine clinics like this one at an
lgbtq community center in white plains
new york are popping up around the
country we're here to protect our
community and ensure that everyone who's
at risk is getting vaccinated the demand
for monkey pox vaccines continues to
skyrocket nationwide with cases roughly
doubling by the week in some states
prompting the white house to declare a
public health emergency we are going to
do everything that we can
to end this outbreak u.s cases have
surpassed 7 100 with six states
reporting more than 500 confirmed cases
the vast majority of cases have been
found among men who have sex with men
but health officials stress anybody can
get it at least five children have
contracted the virus monkey pox is
primarily transmitted through
skin-to-skin contact or exposure to
contaminated clothing or bedding but it
can also spread through prolonged close
exposure to respiratory droplets while
it is rarely fatal patients say monkey
pox is excruciating it was one of the
most painful experiences of my life san
francisco was the first major city to
declare a public health emergency and
this week lines formed around the block
outside zuckerberg general hospital for
the vaccine the reality is is that
vaccine supplies in our country are
limited and in washington state
some residents are even driving to
canada they were very willing to
accommodate anybody regardless of
citizenship
more than 600 thousand doses of the
geneos vaccine have been distributed so
far of the 1.1 million doses allocated
by health and human services there's
major concern this morning that's only a
fraction of what's needed right now to
stop the spread of monkey pox michelle
jonathan vigliotti thank you